on this episode I go back outside
because you asked for it
[Music]
[Music]
this is
garyvee everybody this is gary
vay-ner-chuk and this is episode 1 44 of
the ask gary vee show it is a friday
beautiful Friday here in New York City
the Pope is coming through causing a lot
of ruckus traffic-wise
but I'm in a good mood because my
official Jets Eagles prediction is
coming up India's back that always feels
good and and yesterday's show got a lot
of great comments a lot of good feedback
from the show we went deep quite
emotional but a heartache on episode 143
so India let's get into this this show
let's do it almost I I feel satisfied
that I got you on the on the early on
the early come up so
Anthony Oh what happened answer well why
can't we do well I can't we start 144
with some fun fine set you're facing go
ahead Ari
Ari's questions in deep [ __ ] Ari asks
how could I deal with the perfectionism
and feeling like someone else can do it
better preventing me from getting stuff
done I don't even understand live it
again how can i what what do you do no
no read it again I was like you went too
fast how can I deal with perfectionism
sorry good I understand that me thanks
India and feeling like someone else can
do it better got it so he he not only
wants everything to be perfect he always
has a sense that somebody else can do it
better how do you need to get over
yourself like you know the the reality
is I think speed Trump's so much that
I'm blown away by people that get caught
up in this and really it just leads to
you being disproportionately not
successful because you're too slow
you're overthinking things and I feel
like a lot of times people screw things
up by trying to do too much instead of
just letting it be I you know that's why
I like doing one take you know it just
it's gonna be what its gonna be you get
another at-bat another day in the future
like you know I don't know if I can
motivate you through this answer to say
you know get over yourself move on
change I think it is a DNA thing I think
it's tough for people to break out of
that habit
I'm absolutely massively thankful that
I'm completely the other way I probably
go too fast I probably only execute at
94% 96% 87% 91% 86% consistently but I'd
rather do five things then after I just
told you that story you doing one thing
at 97% not even a hundred to begin with
there is no hundred percent already it's
just not the way it really is the market
decides if it was good or if somebody
can do it better there's a level of
anxiety
and a little bit of like getting over it
that you're just gonna have to do the
fact that you're asking the question
means you're self-aware that's an issue
I think the best way to get things done
in life is to just do them right like
you're gonna learn how to swim by
jumping in the pool and learning how to
swim I think the number one thing you
can do is make the next four to six
projects and make it painful for
yourself just let it go see what happens
when you start tasting like oh wait a
minute that wasn't so bad
away you go people overthink India it's
over thinking guys it's just it's over
thinking
excuse me excuse me do you think people
overthink too much yeah
so we're thinking she had no interest on
being on the show you I asked my company
brokers commodities from the producers
hedgers to the consumers all of my
current and potential customers are
large commercial and industrial property
owners what would be the best way for me
to leverage social media marketing to
try and increase my customer base in
this strictly b2b atmosphere PS Chris
Ivery is a boss of course I've raised a
boss I think he might not play this week
for the Jets I'm concerned I would go
out and create white papers on
SlideShare and then run LinkedIn and
Facebook ads against those white papers
what I mean by that is when you go into
a b2b environment I believe that
long-form becomes much more valuable
than short form I think that you reverse
the headlines that people think that it
needs to be all short form content I
think you know your audience you know
who your buyers are in a b2b environment
you know what they value and you need to
deliver on that and so that's exactly
what I would do I would go out and I
would create long-form content that's
valuable to them and not a sales pitch
that's valuable to you but content that
those decision-makers need not just from
what you do for a living but
holistically let me give you an example
even though I'm trying to get CMOS as
clients I might be able to put out
content that teaches them about cloud
computing or IT infrastructure or I make
a white paper of how the CMO needs to
interact with a CIO these are valuable
pieces of content that I brought to them
that have nothing to do with hire me as
an agency to do your work but I brought
you value in a nine-page deck that you
saw on LinkedIn because I targeted you
properly so that's what I would think
about create long-form content and video
and audio but indefinitely deck form b2b
people love decks and and get that in
front of them through targeting on
LinkedIn and Facebook put your branding
on the bottom make the last click go to
your world provide them that value do
what I always say become a media company
not just around what you do for a living
but what actually brings them value
so what I would do is I would call and
let's get real tactical I would
literally call the 25 customers 50
customers you have right now call them
and say hey real quick if you've got two
minutes or maybe email them because
people don't like people calling email
them said you have two minutes for me
I'm looking to provide you more value
you call them and say hey what are your
other business problems or frictions
besides what we do together in the world
if eight out of 25 of them say the same
thing that would become my first content
pillar to put out to the world bringing
value to people is an amazing way to
guilt them into doing business with you
even if you bring value to them in a
genre that has nothing to do with your
own but is still within the collective
cohesive unit of what they do for a
living
stephane fire emoji out of my mouth at
the end there were time the entire team
was so much going on in the question
we're not really sure we want to see if
you understand it because none of us of
course I understand that this is the
askgaryvee show india go ahead I
understand that he co-owns true karate
schools okay good
like in influential Westchester New York
I think he means yeah I mean in just a
mush he just means Westchester he was
just hyperbolized in Westchester
Lizzie's from Westchester Big Ups my
handle is not instructor I handle the
business side I'm not a karate
instructor okay stick with me India
how do I tell members I'm now a realtor
okay who what's the name Excel martial
art excel martial arts I assume what
you're saying is you do business
development for to karate studios in
Westchester all your social media has
been around that and now you're making a
segue into becoming a realtor and
selling homes in the market you're
speaking to the right guy I told the
world for nine years or for 15 years
that I was a wine merchant and that I
was a wine connoisseur and that I was a
wine expert and then just by putting out
business content because I had the chops
I told him that I was a business
personality if you know what you're
talking about as a realtor
if you know nice photobomb I appreciate
that I got you know if if if you
actually know what you're talking about
from a realtor standpoint and you have
smart points of view on the neighborhood
dynamics the upsides in which
neighborhoods in Westchester are blowing
up things of that nature then I think
you have a huge opportunity and so the
answer is quite simple
the final line is how do I now tell them
I'm real
members so wonder if he's trying to sell
people that are coming in for karate to
like buy a home you know the answer is I
wouldn't sell them in the studio I would
just start putting out content across
all social platforms with your points of
view not just selling a home and saying
hey come to my open house this weekend
no say things like you know I see a huge
opportunity in White Plains and south of
the train station I see that as a level
in Harrison they have a great school
system like those kind of things provide
value provide value provide value guys
we're 144 shows in if you don't
understand that you need to provide
value versus selling to people then you
should stop watching the goddamn show we
got through that one all right Kevin
asks how can illustrate or market
themselves and distinguish themselves
from the competition ooh that's nice I
look like Jake bettin Ruby a little bit
in that you see it I'm changing my angle
here on you a little bit direct um I
think illustrators should really focus
on snapchat
I think snapchats a really interesting
place where they can pop I think that
Facebook targeting publishers so
creating illustrations and then running
$50 worth ads against employees of
publishers I think is a very smart place
to go because I think people will notice
and that and then and then I think what
really really would work is responding
to people on Twitter around subject
matters and then creating illustrations
around those subject matters I think has
enormous upside if you can show your
speed to illustrate around conversation
in that environment I think there's a
real opportunity so those are three
tactics
I mean look an illustrator is gonna
break out from the heap by being a great
illustrator how often you could put
yourself in a position to have people
see your work is going to become the way
that you're successful I also think
illustrate hacking meaning making
illustrations of Gary Vee is gonna I
don't like using third person making
illustrations of me is gonna make me see
it I would go after other micro
influencers not a list celebrities who
are immune for that stuff
but other micro influencers illustrate
them reply to them
I think that's an enormous opportunity
put it on the Instagram and then tag
them cuz they'll see it those kind of
things are cool Anthony asks hey Gary
Vee who's your all-time favorite jet and
all-time least favorite jet and why my
all-time favorite jet and my all-time
least favorite jet my all-time least
favourite jet is probably Kyle Wilson he
just ended it being a jet Kyle if you're
watching this I apologize it's just the
truth
it was a first-round pick he was
terrible every second of the way just
broke my heart just did not like the way
he played didn't feel that he had ball
skills for for a corner even when like
our starting corners would get hurt he
would have to not play he was a terrible
slot I just really disliked him well my
favorite all-time jet is al tune I was a
young kid he was our best receiver
number 88 I loved him with all my heart
I love you al tune if you're watching
and and that's it those are the real
answers to that question that's it
that's a show all right
official prediction time this one's
gonna hurt I have a feeling that Decker
and ivory are not playing I'm uh I think
the Eagles are playing for their lives I
think that the Jets I I don't think the
Jets have never beaten the Eagles in NFL
history in a regular season game and and
I'm very very concerned of this I'm
still very affected by the 1994 93-94
game where the Jets were up 21-7 against
the Eagles at home and an Eric Allen had
a 99 yard interception return for a
touchdown as the Jets were about to go
up 20 to 7 and Johnny Mitchell's
coming-out party game Eagles went on to
win there's just something bad about
this game I'm taking a ton of
vaynermedia Eagle fan employees Mark
Evans a Brandon Resnick and Taggart and
Lindsey price I think I'm bringing too
many employees to the game that feels
wrong and I think the Jets
the Jets stumble here I think that uh I
think they stumble here unfortunately
I'm gonna go Eagles 20 jets 16 hurts my
feelings to go that route but that's
that's my official prediction I'm not
gonna predict them to win every week I
will not be surprised if they win I feel
nice that they could win but my official
prediction is that Jets stumble this
week 20 to 16 but just to give you some
insight I think they rally next week in
London anything can change but that's
how I feel sorry for myself you keep
asking questions I'll keep answering
them
[Music]